i have 158 pending challenges
let's do a random sub
okay a lot of rapping games tonight i'm
keeping it chill
this is casual i'll continue i've been
white every
game so far this stream have another e4
oh chen's a challenge
i'm always conflicted i sometimes feel
bad like people
people sub or donate and they want to
they want a game but i'm trying to keep
it fair for
as fair as i can so
the requests for games are in very high
demand
um are we gonna have a stafford
we might have a staffer
let's punish the stafford stafford
accepted
no halloween gambit
i think i'll play
and there's so many lines i can play
um light c3 d3
i think i'll play e5 one of the more
ambitious lines
okay so this is yeah this is what i play
this black so the trap here is if i play
if i plays d3 bishop c5 is winning for
black
so the traditional move is d4
there's a few alternatives queen f3
queen e2
we'll stay traditional play d4
just preventing bishop e5
yeah we'll see how booked up my opponent
is here
bishop b4 allowing me to win connect for
a bishop b4 is not the move i i
recommend even though it does develop
with tempo
um it gives me the initiative
now i can start developing with tempo
and knight has very few squares
i should note f3 maybe would look
attractive to some people
but would run into queen h4 g3 knight g3
thanks for the advice eric seven month
sub but been enjoying your content for
much longer
oh nice keep up the great thanks so much
rookie move
also my opponent wants to mate me in one
move
so let's this would be a bad position to
mouse slip
let's play queen f3
defending attacking the knight
not too many options for black
oh the command i do have a single course
uh
use the london command um
i'll link to my london course which i
made a few years ago but it's still
i think still somewhat popular
among the london fans
yeah knight g5 one of the only ways to
save the knight
i think i'll play queen g3 would be
extra solid
so the other day i played hikaru
in the stafford i played the stafford
against him and then
he played staff against me but the game
i played against him
he was white he got this kind of amazing
pawn structure
which looks like i'm about to get
and the video actually the video where i
played him
will be posted to youtube in about eight
hours from now or maybe
maybe what i'll do i'll just post it
when i end the stream
especially for those who didn't see it
that's probably better upload time
because i don't want to post it during
the the candidate schemes
you are such a friendly guy with a
calming voice oh thank you
hope everything in your life goes well
oh that's so kind thank you
dog golden guns
i appreciate that
um there's so much fun to be had in this
position i mean f
oh wait a minute did i blunder
also what's with the lag yeah when i
played f4 i blundered this pawn
oh but if takes i have before
[Music]
okay it was all all planned kind of
not really but
yeah it would have worked out okay so
i'm just defending the pawn another time
i want to play f5 and
yeah enjoy life even more
one goal is to win like connect six
along this diagonal
like the only way to get connect six
along a diagonal
is either this one or this one
okay um yeah that was one of the few sad
squares for the night let's keep
developing
oh it's bedtime thanks for the bedtime
stream bits
welcome back psychedelic gazelle i'm
curious how many people are watching
this
maybe drifting off to sleep
i'm gonna avoid playing like loud music
or making loud noises
or screaming
i have this move
black's trying to
hurt my pawn structure
i mean i also have this move okay so no
i i can't get connect six along the
diagonal
i could get it along the fifth rank
there's some idea to play this and then
knight c4 trapping the bishop
thank you og x triple x og
and breakfast sandwich seven
both subbing for the first time oh
okay so i'll take this way
unleashing the rook
so i have i have the two half open uh
rook files i still have all eight pawns
too
um black pieces are
kind of confined to the eighth rank
this is so pleasant i feel kind of bad
but
i feel more good than bad
yeah i'll play c5 pawns are smiling
now this one pawn fixes a bishop which
blocks a other
or fixes a pawn which blocks a bishop
and blocks him knight
so knight has one legal move which you
can't really play
that's a reasonable move
let's just keep improving
pawns go marching one by one
now i can take oh but if i
the problem with taking is after takes
takes
takes my my f5 pawn is gone
so i'll play this move how about
i'll try and bring another pawn to the
center because why not
okay that's fine let's uh push g4
so what i probably want to do oh
[Music]
again black trying to disturb my hopes
and dreams
i have this move actually
wait i have to calculate so g6
i mean everything's winning
g6 takes i think i
actually no not g6 maybe i just take and
play this
yeah let's do that
or maybe d5 immediately
having too much fun here
yeah the problem with g6 is uh
a bishop is attacked
and f7 was well defended
okay so i i have connect five i still
haven't lost a pawn
pawns continue to march
oh thanks for the connect 5 bits
yeah now i wanna probably just wanna
play b4 like
kind of keep the beauty these pawns
completely restrict the knight
i still have a plan the simple plan of
doubling up is actually hard for
black to meet
there's so few defensive resources on
the king's side
oh thank you and tilly says i'm the goat
man
i was sharing the other day uh as an old
video
where i was raised by goats
so this is me this was taken
2006
2005 2004 maybe i don't know
yeah it was back when like uh
i don't think iphones existed yet it's
taken with like a real camera i was
trying to share the
chess book with the goats
um
[Music]
usually when people say goat in chat
they're referring to the
acronym but do we sacrifice the goats
for compensation i didn't sacrifice any
goats in this video i was just trying to
to share my knowledge of chess i don't
want to trade off a
pair of pawns but i probably kind of
have to
unless i play this move
uh but that's not necessary okay so i'll
take here
about to lose my first pawn of the game
but then i'll have this move it's like
um
a trapezoid just without the bass
right trapezoid
it's been so long since i've studied
geometry
yeah the indestructible trapezoid
don't mess with my pawn trapezoid
what you what do you call a
three-dimensional trapezoid
a pyramid maybe
but maybe not rook a7 depositional idea
okay so i have this move
keep marching
this is too much fun
i really hope lee chess lee chess is
lagging can't handle my
pawn structure we just better not like
just crash especially
given what's about to happen
the king the king was in between all
four squares for a very
very brief period of time there it was
like one of those um
what's the physics concept
something position superposition
when like a proton is existing in
multiple places
yeah superposition
could be hard to checkmate the king when
it's on
like fg 7.5
it's on like the intersection of squares
but okay here
i mean there's many different ways to
finish this off
let's be
[Music]
should i be civil or should i be like
ben feingold
i kind of want to be like ben feingold
no we'll be civil
and the torture thank you silverback hq
um that was a pleasant finish
pleasant game if you want content
where one side like under promotes to
seven bishops or seven nights
etc you should watch ben feingold
mainly etc okay that was probably
youtube worthy
not every day you get pawns this
immaculate
um yeah i don't know if i'll title this
don't mess with my pawn trapezoid
oh i have to i'm trying to do more of
this where i
i record myself for the thumbnail
so maybe i'll i'll stare at the the
pawns
in a loving way or a shocked way
or a happy way i have to work on my
facial expressions
smiling
can i touch it oh i can
wha what's like youtube what's a
stereotypical youtube thumbnail
stereotypical
yeah like this
so i need to make this expression
while looking at the pawn cube
wait
okay i think i got it
okay i think i'll take that as a
screenshot let's learn a thing or two
from this game
too apart from just celebrating and
making thumbnails
okay um so one one takeaway
because this is a line i think more
people are playing these days like
they're learning
the the better lines against stafford
um of course d3 this is a nice trap
you know there's been hundreds of people
that have fallen into this
on le chess
um if d4 the move i recommend is queen
h4
hitting the pawn threatening maiden one
and another trap is if white plays g3
which
is third most popular then
black can take on g3
so there's this pin and if f takes is
queen e4 winning
the rook so
um of course white has ways to avoid
that
most common move is queen f3 i was
actually having a few games
was it yesterday or two days ago kind of
in the title arena from this position
where i i like to play f6
i think this move creates the most
amount of chaos
uh challenging the pawn so if takes we
just take back
and and there's some easy development
like bishop here
could end up casting this way or this
way and use the files
so it's very natural for white to play
g3 here
tied for most popular move and then we
can counter attack with knight g5
oh all of these are my games yeah so i'm
sharing uh
some more in-depth preparation so knight
g5 hitting the queen
and then we're also hitting the pawn
because discovered attack
so it's very natural for white to move
the queen to defend the pawn
um we can address bishop g5 too but
let's say queen e3
then we can temporarily sack the queen
queen takes d4
winning back the pawn and then after
takes
we have the fork so it's nice bit of
opening preparation
and this is i think equalizing or no
this is already better for black
this position is it's close to equal if
white
the move i was running into the other
days takes and then takes and then
yeah then it's just equal material
actually knight f3 first is interesting
oh this is a cool line king e2 95
fg7 and bishop g4
and black has a lot of compensation
yeah i would play this actually because
we're threatening this to win the
the thing
um okay so it develops or discovered a
small wrinkle there
with um with knight f3 check
and then i guess the other move to
address after g3 knight g5 bishop big g5
we just take back and then we're
threatening queen here and then we have
the idea of this and this
computer will still say white's better
but
in a quick time control game i think
it's very playable
so hopefully this provides some value to
my opponents
and all the other stafford players